what's up emma how's it going i have had
um a rough couple of months
and it just seems like the thing i don't
know just i need to say the hits keep
coming
but um i need some help trying to find
a corner in the circular room that i can
start
to try and rebuild um where i'm at where
my family's at
where my marriage is at um so walk me
through it's honestly
where i'm at um about
let's see no not about over there's a
lot of stuff leading up to this but
a little back story is when i was 24 my
father passed away suddenly
when i was 26 or 27
my daughter had to have emergency heart
surgery ended up having to have five
heart surgeries and then so and then
anyway my father passed away right after
i was married then
my daughter needs all these surgeries
fast forward to now today
okay so that was like 10 years ago so
you're 37 now
i'm sorry you're 37 now no um i
am um yeah yeah 40. 37
21 right yeah exactly perfect
um so over thanksgiving
my husband who has been i knew was an
alcoholic
but he never admitted it finally
admitted it and we stopped drinking
okay and so that's good it's great right
i mean that's i've been so proud of him
and that's something that i'm just
you know it's the one thing in my life
i'm like this is good
but at the same time you know it's been
a struggle because
you know he has to go through all of
these in these challenges
um and then in january
um uh i found out i was doing some
research because i've been taking over
our finances
and i found out that he had stolen
approximately 72 thousand dollars out of
our 401k
technically okay but that's over
seven years so that's like 10 000 a year
that he was sneaking and stealing and
you know just
to buy technically to buy the booze and
to buy
other stuff that he wanted and he always
told me it was called gun money where i
thought he was buying guns fixing them
up and selling them
and i really just gave him full you know
like i trusted him i really trusted him
um and then recently like in the last
couple of weeks
he he got an offer oh he he also quit so
he was in the alcohol industry
and now he's um he went and then he
switched over to olive oil or some
another commodity which i was like
super excited about that he wasn't happy
and now we just got a new opportunity to
take
a job in the alcohol industry again
um but he says it's his dream job and
i told him that i was you know had my
reservations and
um and he took it anyway so but the
problem with the job is it's like five
and a half hours away so we have to move
to be there and i feel like it's just a
lot i mean that's just
in a short period of time like i mean i
don't know if i've ever
i mentioned my father and my daughter
because i don't know if i ever got over
that
you know so it just feels like
everything was like what i could have
put away to the side i may have to deal
with now
and all of this with my husband how many
kids do you have
we have three children how long have you
been married
uh 18 years
is um it's gonna get right to it is your
marriage over
i don't i don't know i don't think so um
you don't think so
but does he think so no he doesn't think
so he
is a hundred percent let me ask it this
way
you've let him do for a decade
yeah he was an alcoholic and you knew it
and you let him he was functioning like
it was it was like more like
hey i'm gonna go sit by the fire and
drink till i fall asleep
right so like i said you knew it and
yeah right when you're married to an
alcoholic
that impacts your intimate life that
impacts your sleep life it impacts your
well hey that's just dad life it impacts
your kid it impacts everything
even if they're a functioning alcoholic
it impacts everything and it just
becomes that's just the way he is
but you knew it and i'm not blaming you
i'm just laying it out here so that you
can see his perspective
he's been able to do whatever he wants
and then he just
made an extra 10 grand every year taking
money from the family's future
to do whatever he wants because he's
been allowed to do whatever he wants
and yeah
here's what i know i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna blame you i'm not gonna shame you
anything like that
one month or two months if my wife's
like hey i got some extra this or
something
cool that's a thousand bucks a month
that's 800 a month or whatever yeah over
10 years and so he robbed you for 10
years
and you chose to look the other
direction for 10 years
and now you're not blaming you i'm just
saying
from his perspective he runs this house
he does whatever he wants whenever he
wants
right and now he's just taking another
job
that's going to kill him that's going to
go back to the way things were
in another town and you know what y'all
are just going to get in the boat and
come along
because that's the way it works and so
when i ask you is your marriage over
that's what i'm asking you and what i'm
saying is
is it just going to be the way it was or
is this the moment when you say no more
because if it's the way it if it's just
the way it's going to be then it's just
the way it's going to be
and if you're going to say you know what
not this time i'm not moving this time
i'm not i'm not going to go back to
having you be an alcoholic work in this
environment i'm not going to
just pretend that you didn't put us in
the whole 75 thousand dollars times
compound interest over a decade times
over three decades which is a lot of
money
it makes me sick because i'm all about
financial stability
right and you had to be about financial
stability because you weren't about
relational stability
your dad poof was a vapor right you
almost lost your baby
several times right you lived in the
shadow of a functioning alcoholic
right and so financial security became
the thing you could control
and even that got slipped through your
fingers right
exactly and we're living in our dream
house right now i'm trying to fix it
you know um and during all this time we
knew we were going to do foundation
repair
on it so i started all this foundation
repair he's he's working
monday through friday you know five and
a half hours away
good news is he's living with his
parents so and his parents are
and i are kind of on the same page they
don't know about the embezzlement
embezzlement but they do know about the
alcohol and um
what did he say when you confronted him
about the money um
he he like
he took full responsibility and i asked
him i said
i think you need to research and find
out how much it is i said but you need
to know that i'm going to research and
find out how much it is
so he researched and found out 32 000
when i researched
i found out the 72 because i'm really
good with finances and i can find out
when people are taking money
i know i know but listen okay so let's
pretend you and i
are having coffee and i showed up okay
and i said my husband's stealing from me
when i called him on it he lied about it
he went on this big i'm so sorry
expedition i'm going to find out how
much he lied by half
he's been an alcoholic he finally got
away from it
and then he just packed up and moved
five and a half hours away in with his
parents
and took another job and what would you
tell me
emma your your marriage is over it's on
the rocks
it is drowning this isn't about
foundation this isn't about
money thievery this isn't about it's
about
y'all are living two completely separate
lives
and you've got a picture that you are
taking bits of information
and trying to um put it this way it's
like a puzzle
and there's missing pieces and so you
have a piece of construction paper
underneath this puzzle and you're
coloring it in trying to make it the
puzzle
work together and it's not because he
just keeps taking more pieces because he
can take whatever he wants
and at some point you got to get a car
and y'all got to meet
probably with somebody and you got to
just put it out there and say do you
want to be my husband because if you
want to be my husband this is what it's
going to look like
right i do want to have a relationship
with him i just want to be able to work
this out
i mean i just but he's got to be able to
want to do that too yeah he says he does
he he says he does
i know but then he i know but behavior
is a language
yeah he says he does and then he took a
job five and a half hours away moved in
with his parents and
got back in the alcohol industry yeah
the reason he also took
the job is because it makes more money
sure great
the the money that he took but listen
when i wasn't well my wife and i took a
70 000
household pay cut to move to a new city
and i took a new job so we could i could
get well so she could get well so we
could heal our marriage
great i don't care how much money he's
making i don't i'd rather him
quit and go work at starbucks and
rebuild himself and your relationship
from the floor up
together with you not
not be further deceitful not be further
selfish not
further put you guys relationally back
even further in order to chase down this
money and try to get it back and
man no way jose dude
you got to just somebody's got to throw
the flag on this deal turn all the
lights in the stadium on
and y'all got to walk out and meet at
the 50 yard line and say what are we
doing
i want to be your wife you say you want
to be my husband and here's the world
we're living in
because a team who has here's the other
thing
after he stole from the family
stole from your kid's future stole from
y'all's future
and then lied about it and then took
another job
you'll have to rebuild something new
you're not just going to get back to the
way things were and by the way the way
things were were no good he was a
functioning alcoholic that you let do
whatever he wanted to do
you guys got to build something new
and then he packed up and moved and left
you to deal with the foundation and
three kids and and and
so you all have to get in a room
excavate what was
because what was is gone and decide do
we want to get an architect an engineer
and a builder and build something new
and if we do what is that going to look
like that's going to look like a couple
that makes
five hour moves to gather decisions
together we take new jobs together we
raise our kids together
we rise and fall with your sobriety
together
you don't conspire with his parents to
keep an eye on him he's a grown man he
can do what he wants to and he's been
able to forever
and so here's the thing your marriage
it's not over i shouldn't have said it
like that
it is on a ventilator it's on a
ventilator
it is gasping for air and i want to see
you
um turn all the lights on the hospital
and pull the hoses out and say we're
going to make this thing right
all right thanks for that call emma um
y'all got a lot of work to do
let me know how that journey goes but
make that call this weekend let's get on
it